bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
spéciale proposée par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 21 octobre
voici les titres l'hommage national à
samuel pâtit ce professeur assassiné par
un terroriste à conflans sainte honorine
se déroule ce soir à 19h30 à la sorbonne
à paris dans les yvelines de nombreux
rassemblements sont aussi prévus
nous retrouverons plusieurs journalistes
de la rédaction de tv 78 en direct de
villepreux voisins le bretonneux ou
encore elancourt l'hommage de conflans
sainte honorine a lui eu lieu hier soir
une marche blanche qui a rassemblé
plusieurs milliers de personnes était
organisée en son honneur
notre invité c'est laurent bros maire
divers droite de conflans sainte
honorine
il s'est exprimé au micro de tv 78
pendant la marche blanche dans sa
commune
très ému il revient sur cet acte de
barbarie
pour cette journée d'hommage national
nous serons tout au long de cette
édition en direct dans plusieurs villes
yvelinoise à vivre avec célia get on go
à 3 1 le bretonneux avec astrid bergère
ou encore à elancourt avec justin
brasier ces trois villes organisent des
marches blanches ou des rassemblements
en l'honneur de samuel petit pâtit
pardon peu de temps avant l'hommage
national
nous les retrouverons dans quelques
instants cet hommage national justement
rendu à samuel pâtisser ce soir il se
déroulera donc à la sorbonne à paris à
partir de 19h pour saluer la mémoire de
ce professeur d'histoire géographie
assassiné par un terroriste comme je
vous le disais en titre pour avoir
enseigné la liberté d'expression à ses
élèves
le président emmanuel macron lui
remettra d'ailleurs la légion d'honneur
à titre posthume en présence de sa
famille
le cercueil arrivera ensuite vers 19h30
dans la cour d'honneur de la sorbonne
dans les yvelines plusieurs hommages
était organisée donc aujourd'hui parmi
eux saint cyr l'école où s'est déroulée
une marche blanche
le cortège est parti à 16 heures depuis
le collège jean racine pour une arrivée
à l'hôtel de ville
bixente mais rien senti steban a
rencontré la mère sonia bros et suivi
bergala proviseur au lycée professionnel
jean perrin ça permet à la fois pour les
élèves de saint cyr à la fois pour le
corps enseignant pour les élus d'une
manière générale de dire notre tristesse
aujourd'hui et surtout de rendre hommage
à un homme qui est tombé pour ses
valeurs et pour la liberté d'expression
symboliquement oui c'est très très fort
voilà on parle de cet établissement le
collège jean racine et on va arriver à
la mairie au lieu de la république et
donc c'est extrêmement important pour
nous que de pouvoir assurer cette marche
autres ce rassemblement pendant cette
journée nationale d'hommage et celui ci
a lieu en ce moment même à villepreux
c'est une marche blanche qui est
organisée nous rejoignons célia gars
tsongo qui est en direct sur place s'il
ya bonsoir qu'est ce qui est prévu pour
cette marche blanche
alors je me trouve sur le parvis de
l'hôtel de ville de villepreux
le maire jean baptiste à mo'nique a
voulu organiser une marche blanche en
l'honneur de l'enseignant tués samuel
pâtit derrière moi des centaines et des
centaines de personnes avec des roses
blanches à la main 7 mars va débuter
dans quelques instants
elle passera par le clos crosse sciés
puis le lycée sonia-delaunay tu pour se
terminer devant le collège léon blum où
une gerbe de fleurs sera déposée
s'ensuivent plusieurs discours un
dictionnaire au dessus bien entendu du
maire de villepreux puis aussi du député
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
philippe benassaya
merci célia pour ces précisions et vous
allez évidemment suivre cette marche
le reportage sera à retrouver demain
dans notre édition du 7 8 journal nous
rejoignons manon astrid bergère qui est
en direct de voisins-le-bretonneux la
ville organise elle aussi un
rassemblement et une minute de silence
quelle est l'ambiance actuellement
astrid on me dit que c'est la minute de
silence justement en ce moment
on va fermer plus tard ça vous convient
pour respecter cette minute de silence
justement parmi eux aussi dans
l'actualité les nombreux rassemblements
yvelinois en hommage à samuel pâtit
certaines villes elles ont fait le choix
de l'organiser hier soir mardi ou bien
ce matin comme trappe guyancourt ou
encore magny les hameaux
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
bixente mais rien senti steban et astrid
bergère les hommages continuent dans les
yvelines mardi 20 octobre à magny les
hameaux l'appui n'a pas empêcher les
habitants de venir se recueillir à
l'appel de la municipalité
ici à magny les hameaux il était
essentiel de pouvoir se rassembler pour
pouvoir montrer aussi notre union
face
des terroristes qui essayent de nous
diviser et surtout de de pouvoir
rappeler notre attachement à nos valeurs
de liberté d'égalité de fraternité de
laïcité
ça me paraissait important de venir pour
dire que l'école et est importante en
france que les enfants ont la chance de
pouvoir venir gratuitement et dans la
plupart du temps dans de très bonnes
conditions
c'est le combat
[Musique]
ce mercredi à guyancourt un autre
hommage a eu lieu devant l'hôtel de
ville les habitants sont venus apporter
leur soutien à la famille de samuel pâti
des personnes se sont battus pour la
liberté la liberté d'expression est
aujourd'hui à mourir dans des conditions
telles qu'elles barbare je trouve ça
inadmissible inacceptable de confession
musulmane cette guyancourt toise veut
éviter à tout prix les annales gamme
j'aimerais que la société d'aujourd'hui
nous compare pas à eux
voilà c'est important pour pour nous
adultes pour nos enfants dans l'islam on
ne tue pas au nom de dieu c'est un péché
l'importance du vivre ensemble c'est
aussi ce que vous lui montrez des
habitants de trappes en se rassemblant
pour l'hommage rendu c'est mercredi midi
ça nous a touchés et ça nous a fait mal
au coeur et on verra lui rendent hommage
voilà et partager cet hommage avec les
trappistes
je pense que chacun est concerné quelles
que soient ses origines
quelle que soit sa religion même s'ils
sont athées comme moi mais je pense que
chacun doit vivre ensemble et c'est
l'essentiel ce une très publique
aujourd'hui on a tendance à se dévier
sur certains éléments alors qu'en fait
on ne focalise pas sur ce qui nous
fédère et entre 11 et 11 il gêne à ce
qui nous fédère est plus forte que ce
qui doit ou peut nous diviser n'a pas
toujours tous les mêmes opinions et la
laïcité c'est aussi ça respecter
l'opinion des autres
l'hommage national à samuel bâti sur un
rendu ce mercredi à partir de 19h il
recevra la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume et sera fait commandeur des
palmes académiques
nous rejoignons à nouveau à ce tri
bergère à voisins le bretonneux en
direct par égard et par respect pour la
minute de silence qui se déroulait tout
à l'heure nous avons coupé votre direct
mais quelle est l'ambiance aujourd'hui
justement après sept minutes de silence
astrid
oui léonard alors je me trouve sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux le rassemblement
touche à sa fin le ca cela a commencé
par un discours de la mer et puis un
discours qui était touchant elle a
rappelé l'importance de l'éducation et
du vivre ensemble
et puis il ya eu cette minute de silence
et enfin dépôt de gerbe sur le monument
aux morts derrière moi j'avais beaucoup
le monde beaucoup d'habitants sont venus
ce soir et là les gens discutent
échangent des mots et et voilà c'est la
fin du rassemblement
eh bien merci astrid et comme je le
disais pour célia qui était à villepreux
vous suivrez vous aussi ce rassemblement
et nous aurons plus de précisions demain
dans le 7-8 journal partons désormais à
elancourt ou justin brasier nous attend
en direct elle aussi du rassemblement
prévu par la mairie à 18h30
donc on est un tout petit peu avant ce
rassemblement comment ça se passe
actuellement justin je vois que vous
avez quelqu'un avec vos feux oui
exactement alors déjà il honore et je me
trouve sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
où va se passer le rassemblement alors
il n'a pas commencé puisqu'il débutera à
18h30 mais vous pouvez le voir il y a
déjà beaucoup d'élan pour toi qui sont
présents pour cet hommage à samuel paty
et notamment qui sera suivie après par
une minute de silence
alors je suis avec luca luca qui
bâtissent par nos bâtisses qui est au
collège en cinquième
baptiste est ce que tu peux nous dire un
peu pourquoi tu es venu à cet hommage
vache est venu pour rendre hommage à
samuel pâtit un prof d'histoire géo qui
a été assassiné et décapité et voilà et
tu te sens un peu concernée puisque tu
au collège j'imagine bah oui parce que
pour certains s'élèvent ça peut faire
mal devant un prof d'entendre qu'un prof
s'effectuer et back home show klg à jour
je pense que j'aimerais pas que ça ça se
passe avec un mes profs c'est bah voila
quoi si merci baptiste pour cette
réponse ici beaucoup d'émotion
d'incompréhension et de tristesse
eléonore face à l'événement tragique qui
s'est produit vendredi
voilà ce que je peux vous dire
actuellement merci justin pour ces
précisions et merci à ce jeune homme
d'avoir témoigné dans cette édition
spéciale
si l'hommage national se déroule donc ce
soir la ville de conflans sainte
honorine
elle a rendu d'abord un hommage locales
à samuel pâtit c'était hier soir des
milliers de personnes ont participé à la
marche blanche organisée en son honneur
reportage
[Applaudissements]
les applaudissements ils ont été très
nombreux lors de la marche blanche
organisée mardi soir en l'honneur de
samuel pâtit ce professeur d'histoire
géographie assassiné par un terroriste
car il enseignait la liberté
d'expression à ses élèves
des milliers de personnes ont participé
à cet hommage locale la marche blanche
est partie du collège le bois d'aulne où
il travaillait pour rejoindre la place
de la liberté
un symbole fort voulue par la
municipalité entre tristesse colère et
vocalement cette marche blanche n'est
pas neutre la liberté d'expression ce
n'est pas qu'un mot c'est la liberté de
lire ses rêves y était pensé c'est la
liberté d'écrire faire la liberté de se
syndiquer fait la liberté de s'associer
fait la liberté de revendiquer fait la
liberté de voter et ça on oublie
enlèvera pas beaucoup de sentiments en
fait
de la tristesse parce que je fasse ça
reste un acte terrible confluence est
passé de la ville inconnue à une ville
qui fait la une des journaux et pas
forcément pour les bonnes raisons
et puis certaines elle c'était
nécessaire parce que je pense que tout
le monde était très tôt chez moi ma mère
est enseignante
donc je comprends totalement
l'aberration qu'on a tous face à cet
événement
samuel patier désormais un symbole celui
du garant des valeurs de la république
grâce à son enseignement la liberté
d'expression mais aussi la fraternité et
l'égalité continueront à être transmise
comme l'attestent en de ses anciens
élèves devenus professeurs ça me touche
vraiment ça touche aussi mes élèves
il ya deux jours enfin dimanche soir
j'ai reçu un mail d'une ancienne élève
et elle m'a dit qu'elle était touchée
que que dans mes cours
on donnait beaucoup d'importance aux
débats du coup à travers mes sympathies
ça lui avait rappelé les cours qu'elle
avait avec moi et ça m'a vraiment
interpellé parce que moi je lui mets
seipati il m'a transmis quelque chose et
peut-être qu'à mon tour j'ai transmis
quelque chose aux générations suivantes
samuel pâtit recevra la légion d'honneur
à titre posthume
ce soir un dernier hommage national
cette fois ci lui est rendu à la
sorbonne à paris
le maire de conflans-sainte-honorine
laurent bros étaient évidemment présents
hier soir à la marche blanche avec
mélanie poquet il nous a accordé une
interview
comme on peut s'en douter il est
extrêmement ému
bonsoir alors en brosse vous êtes le
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine ou
s'est passé ce drame absolu
quelle réaction aujourd'hui avez-vous
toujours sous le choc
évidemment les jours passent mais j'ai
toujours très choqué et bouleversé
blessé par ce qui s'est passé le souhait
c'était de retrouver la population
polonaise on a pu faire un formidable
hommage dans la ville de conflans sainte
honorine un hommage digne à samuel pâtit
et puis est important avec la population
que nous nous serrons les coudes pour
que dans les semaines les mois à venir
ça prendra sans doute du temps nous
puissions ensemble nous relever ça vous
tenait à coeur d'organiser cette marche
blanche
donc ce mercredi soir cette fameuse
marche blanche avant l'hommage national
à la sorbonne était fondamental qui est
à mon sens un hommage locales à conflans
sainte honorine préalable à l'hommage
national
j'ai beaucoup changé avec les conflanais
depuis depuis vendredi dernier
tous avaient besoin de parler avait
besoin d'échanger besoin d'être écoutés
et cette marche blanche s'inscrit dans
cette démarche où on a tous besoin de se
retrouver de dire ce qu'on a sur le
coeur et c'est le début de gros de nos
processus de redressement de la ville de
conflans sainte honorine
on sent bien l'émotion pendant cette
marche on sent bien le l'émotion des
gens la colère l'effarement aussi si je
puis dire de cet acte de barbarie
pour vous quelle qu elle est un petit
peu votre sentiment par rapport aux
conflanais vous dites souvent que vous
vous relèverez c'est toujours votre état
d'esprit j'imagine toujours être à
d'esprit on se relèvera simplement il
nous sommes dans une ville nous n'avons
pas l'habitude des phénomènes de
délinquance
encore moins de la barbarie et c'est
d'autant plus choquant pour la
population c'est d'autant plus choquant
pour la population c'est ça prendra du
temps mais je suis je vais dans une
démarche d'échangés avec la population
nous devons aller au plus près des
familles au plus près des enfants de nos
enfants pour leur expliquer pour surtout
les écouter et pour les accompagner et
pour cela je compterai sur évidemment la
communauté éducative mais aussi sur des
quais des éducateurs spécialisés dans
nos quartiers et juste
vous parlez des enfants comment va se
passer cette rentrée au collège sans du
bois d'aulne le pardon le 2 novembre
comment vous l'envisagez comment vous
l'imaginez aujourd'hui chaque jour
suffit sa peine c'est très très délicat
de parler d'eux mêmes de ce qui va se
passer dans à la rentrée dans moins de
deux semaines au collège de bois d'aulne
ça fera l'objet sans aucun doute d'un
échange avec la principale du collège
avec les enseignants avec les
représentants des parents d'élèves pour
que cette rentrée puisse être puisse se
passer au mieux pour les élèves qui
j'imagine auront à n'en pas douter une
certaine appréhension vous allez
j'imagine vous rendre un hommage
national qui a lieu donc mercredi à 19h
à la sorbonne à paris
oui je me je me rendrai déjà pour rendre
hommage à un professeur qui enseignait à
conflans sainte honorine et parce qu'il
faut que notre ville soit représenté à
cet hommage national c c'est important
pour les habitants et pour la communauté
éducative de conflans sainte honorine
merci laurent bros d'avoir été avec nous
et bon courage pour la suite
c'est beaucoup l'enquète se poursuit en
ce qui concerne les responsabilités dans
cet attentat
le procureur antiterroriste jean
françois ricard a donné une conférence
de presse cet après midi il a notamment
annoncé que sept personnes dont deux
collégiens de 14 et 15 ans ont été
déférés devant le juge antiterroriste
les deux collégiens c'est pour avoir
désigné samuel pâti à l'assaillant
contre rémunération de l'ordre de 300 à
350 euros
il a également fait état de plusieurs
contacts entre le parent d'élève qui a
réalisé la vidéo à charge contre
l'enseignant et le terroriste dans cette
vidéo il s'avère que les faits sont je
cite factuellement inexact selon le
procureur antiterroriste
une quinzaine d' enquête a enfin été
ouverte par le parquet de paris pour des
faits d'apologie de terrorisme menace de
mort et provocation après des messages
sur les réseaux sociaux
je rappelle donc que ce soir c'est à
19h30 que se tient l'hommage national en
l'honneur de samuel pâtit on va en
reparler avec vous patrice carmouze
bonsoir soir et d'abord pourquoi avoir
choisi la sorbonne emmanuel macron a
choisi cet endroit pour
d'hommage national à semelle pâtit
raison c'est emmanuel macron qu'il a
choisi en accord avec la famille de
samuel pâtit alors on voit bien pourquoi
parce que c'est évidemment le lieu du
savoir de l'enseignement mais c'est plus
que ça encore à mon avis c'est le lieu
du génie français de génie français
c'est à la fois l'expression de la
liberté et la liberté d'expression et
parfois de la constestation il ya eu mai
68 à la sorbonne et des grandes
contestations à la sorbonne
au fond c'est ça c'est le lieu à la fois
de la liberté de la laïcité d'ailleurs
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer l'a dit il dit la
sorbonne c'est l'incarnation de
l'importance de ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui
et pourtant jusqu'ici les hommages avait
plutôt lieu aux invalides eux sauf si je
me rappelle bien si mes souvenirs sont
bons au pont dans l'attentât du bataclan
en 2015 ce avait eu lieu à la sorbonne
ce qui a eu beaucoup d'étudiants lever
une visite de du président françois
hollande à la sorbonne parce que il y
avait beaucoup d'étudiants qui était bon
au bataclan mais vous avez raison
généralement salut aux invalides eu
depuis longtemps
en gros depuis 240 c'est à dire le
retour des cendres de napoléon en france
pourquoi parce que d'abord c'est souvent
des militaires qui jouent leur vie et
les invalides c'est le pas ce qu'on
appelle le panthéon des militaires et
puis il ya d'ailleurs eu le colonel
beltrame vous savez qui avait quitté
intervenu de manière héroïque dans dole
dans la prise d'otages du supermarché de
très bas était aux invalides mais il
faut dire que c'est quand même des
hommages très codifié peu pontifiant
avec des hommages militaires le passage
des troupes en revue alors ça convient
bien aux militaires ça convient aux
policiers ça convient aussi puisqu'on le
fait aussi beaucoup pour eux aux femmes
et aux hommes politiques
franchement pour un enseignant ce
n'était pas le lieu le mieux indiqué
c'était bien la sorbonne on va entendre
ce soir d'ailleurs pendant cet hommage
national en dehors du discours des
mairies le maquereau évidemment la
lecture de la lettre d'albert camus à
son premier instituteur wii qui
s'appelait louis germain et et c'est une
date qu'il a écrite le jour où il a
appris qu'il allait être récompensée du
prix nobel et j'ai aussitôt un tout
petit extrait il lui dit sans vous sans
votre enseignement sans votre exemple
rien de tout cela ne serait pas arrivé
c'est évidemment un
magnifique hommage à ce qu'est
l'enseignement est ce qu est l
enseignement au métier d'enseignant qui
était celui de samuel pâtit et puis à la
sorbonne il ya deux statues qui sont
importantes c'est celle de victor hugo
et de louis pasteur alors victor hugo
c'est évidemment l'immense écrivain
l'immense poète mais c'est plus que ça
c'est aussi un humaniste et on va se
souvenir de cette phrase célèbre de
victor hugo
ouvrez des écoles vous fermerez une
prison etc ou faux là aussi un hymne un
hommage au savoir à la connaissance et
au fait que l'enseignement et la
connaissance ça éloigne de la violence
et lui du crime et puis louis pasteur là
encore on peut y voir un symbole
d'où le pasteur et c'est lui qui a
trouvé le vaccin contre la rage et
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour
la république sinon bah l'idée de
retrouver le vaccin contre la rage des
barbares et des assassins on se quitte
sur cette jolie métaphore c'est la fin
de cette émission spéciale merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information rom bien
demain à 18 heures dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canale et vous
pourrez revoir cette émission et toutes
les autres sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme ou encore sur notre
application mobile tv 78 je vous
souhaite un très bon
une très bonne soirée
[Musique]